[Musique]
m
merci de nous rejoindre pour un nouveau
v y paie consacre aujourd'hui à mathilde
obino bonjour et bienvenue en plateau
seulement 27 ans originaire du chesnay
déjà un long parcours derrière vous avec
est depuis quelques jours un nouvel
ouvrage le quatrième travail et son
style c'est chez ellipses vous y
expliquait comment à notre époque
prendre goût à l'écriture alors que bien
souvent la mode est à l'abréviation le
fameux style sms alors déjà vous ce goût
pour l'écriture ce goût à l'écriture
vous l'avez vu comment vous l'avez
découvert comment j'ai eu la chance en
la famille on a beaucoup de livres donc
on a eu l'occasion de lire depuis depuis
toujours et c'est vrai qu'en lisant
forcément on se familiarise avec des
histoires des manières d'écrire des mots
des phrases j'ai poursuivi après en
prépa littéraire donc j'avais toujours
cette envie d'écrire et c'est de là
qu'est né le livre que j'ai coécrit avec
l'art absorbés qu'ils étaient en classe
avec moi en prépa puis dans celui des
mes études donc c'était intéressant de
pouvoir formalisé ce goût pour les cris
alors c'est assez paradoxal on n'a
jamais eu autant de moyens de
communiquer et envoyer des messages et
on s'affranchit de plus en plus de
toutes les règles de tous les codes de
l'écriture de l'emploi même quelquefois
du bon mot vous voulez redonner goût à
ces mots comment il ya toute une
rééducation à faire finalement alors
c'est vrai quand on envoie un sms qu'on
va parler très rapidement on emploie des
abréviations et finalement les mots
apparaissent uniquement comme un support
l'idée cet ouvrage était de sensibiliser
les lecteurs et leur dire finalement
c'est possible de savourer les mots en
choisissant bons termes
on peut être plus attentifs à ça en
prenant un synonyme en initiant d'aller
plus loin d'être plus rigoureux aussi
avec les mots on peut raconter d'autres
histoires on peut dire autre chose que
le seul message qu'on veut faire passer
c'est aussi rentrer dans un imaginaire
donc c'est c'est de sensibiliser est là
toute la potentialité qui représente les
mots s'adressent aux plus jeunes
finalement non seulement aux plus jeunes
mais aussi aux adultes qui ont qui ont
soif de curiosité on prend des exemples
dans la serre politique dans la sphère
culturelle dans la littérature en
montrant que c'est possible justement de
faire preuve de curiosité d'aller plus
loin et décide de retrouver goût à
l'écriture je parlais de cette ère du
numérique du digital vous en faites
partie finalement mais vous ne vous
retrouvez pas parmi les plus jeunes
justement ça vous agace quand vous avez
des conversations avec des amis par
exemple
je fais partie en effet de cette aire
qui est familière du digital en étant
présente sur les réseaux sociaux
mais c'est vrai que souvent on a
tendance à penser le digital comme une
finalité
or c'est uniquement et c'est juste un
canal pour faire passer l'idée et voilà
le qu'elle sait juste uniquement un
moyen et ça on a tendance à confondre
son rôle et son moyen donc l'idée c'est
vraiment de revenir sur le digital
uniquement comme levier
ça veut dire que même pour envoyer un
sms vous faites attention j'essaie de me
relier alors je mets des smileys des
temps à autre mais voilà de faire passer
un message de façon claire vous êtes
auteur vous êtes aussi est professeur de
communication communicante ce qui guide
votre parcours professionnel finalement
scellé les changes la rencontre
justement aussi oui l'échangé puis de se
faire entendre auprès des parties
prenantes à qui je vous faire passer un
message est ce que c'est un journaliste
est ce que c'est un responsable des
relations publiques est-ce que c'est un
blogueur est ce que c'est le grand
public et en fonction du message qu'ont
essayé de faire passer justement la
tonalité la structure la potion ne sera
pas le même
et c'est ça que je trouve très
intéressant et c'est comment on essaye
de faire passer au mieux le message en
lien avec la communication qui peut être
une commisération crise
interpersonnelles et ça c'est toujours
très intéressant échange rencontre c'est
ce qui vous a amené aussi à fonder la
saga des audacieux un site internet sur
le leadership pour les décideurs on
revient un petit peu sur l'histoire de
ce site et puis où il en est aujourd'hui
vous l'avez mis de côté ou vous
continuez à côté de votre parcours
professionnel alimenter encore je le
poursuis en mettant toujours en avant
des dirigeants des décideurs des
entrepreneurs l'idée de ce site art jeu
poursuivi mes études en ayant fait
plusieurs expériences dans les médias et
je voulais rassembler les interviews que
j'avais mené sous le prisme et de
l'audace que fuchs est une valeur qui
est importante et et inspirante en
racontant des histoires des parcours de
vie de dirigeant et de décideurs et
voilà j'essaie toujours de varier d'en
raconter sur des univers extrêmement
variés à chaque fois ce sont des
nouvelles des nouvelles histoires des
nouveaux engagements qui sont pris avec
ses portraits je parlais de ces
rencontres je reste sur l'idée de
rencontrer ça jusqu'à l'âge de 15 ans
pardon pardon vous avez fait une
rencontre importante pour vous c'est
celle de laurence ferrari pour parler
oui oui j'ai eu la chance de la suivre
en stage voilà j'étais au lycée j'avais
15 ans et elle était à l'époque chez
story box press et sur canal puis celle
présentée dimanche plus et je trouvais
que c'était très intéressant puisque
c'était la campagne de 2007 pour les
présidentielles de pouvoir suivre parce
qu'elle journalistes que j'admire et je
trouvais que c'était très sympa de sa
part de 2 me suivre et l epu va
transmettre la ténacité sa détermination
et c'est une expérience très
enrichissante
vous qui avez fait qu'ils avaient suivi
justement cette journaliste là qui est
dans la communication vous n'avez jamais
eu envie de vous lancer dans le
journalisme à proprement parler alors
c'est intéressant parce qu'il ya des
liens qui sont qui sont étroits entre
ces univers entre la communication et
journalisme ce qui alors si j'avais fait
en effet des îles d'aru pour les
rencontre aussi sur votre site internet
j'y reviens mais oui c'est vrai que
voilà il ya toujours cette idée et cette
soif d'apprendre de pouvoir retranscrire
ensuite de raconter ses histoires ses
parcours pour les différents publics
après la communication de son univers
aussi intéressant justement de deux
pouvoirs forts de la connaissance des
médias transmis transmettre au mieux aux
différents publics
c'est une autre manière de faire une
autre angle mais en effet il ya toujours
le rapport humain est toujours les
rencontres que vous évoquez qui sont
présents dans ces deux univers vous êtes
ici pour parler de travail et son style
chez ellipses et puis on profite de
cette émission pour vous connaître un
petit peu plus parce qu'on vous a vu à
plusieurs fois sur ce plateau à
l'occasion des différentes sorties de
deux ouvrages et ce dernier ouvrage est
préfacé par une autre rencontre que vous
n'avez pu faire christophe barbier
parlons aussi de cette préface et puis
de de la rencontre avec l'homme peut
être oui alors christophe barbier j'ai
eu l'opportunité aussi de faire un stage
à l'express c'est quelqu'un que j'admire
beaucoup également ses enfants
journaliste engagé puis un homme de
théâtre aussi et que je trouve
intéressant justement son rapport aux
mots à la fois dans la seine dans la
manière dont ils décryptent les
politiques et donc il
il a accepté de faire la préface et on
est très reconnaissante vous en êtes
vous êtes retrouvés autour de ce goût
pour l'écriture ce goût pour le bon mot
justement we will un phrasé une manière
d'écrire est une manière aussi de
percevoir l'actualité que je trouve très
intéressante très rythmé très relevé
aussi donc c'était c'était intéressant
que qui puisse écrire mettre un mot
justement ce rapport au monde je parlais
de rencontre tout à l'heure des
rencontres parfois très loin thème vous
avez un intérêt pour la chine aussi
oui oui j'ai l'occasion de me rendre en
chine il ya trois ans c'était à shanghai
ça a été une véritable claque ce qui
s'est passé l'énergie ti qui s'y passe
et puis j'ai eu l'occasion d'y retourner
à plusieurs reprises à pékin à canton et
à écrire régulièrement avec phil branche
des des tribunes des articles de fond
est en train de poursuivre ce travail
d'écriture de décryptage ce que je
trouve que la chine justement là on la
connaît très peu et voilà une idée
c'était d'approfondir de partir à
l'encontre des deux experts détruit la
chine est depuis la france on la connaît
bleue mais fait peur parfois aussi bien
sur le plan économique aussi aurait
notamment à l'ensemble des décideurs
mondiaux il faut se rassurer ou
s'inquiéter
en tout cas faut apprendre à la
connaître et ne pas se contenter
justement des clichés des ce qui se
passe on parle beaucoup des gaffes
américain mais il ya aussi les béats tx1
l'acronyme chinois qui sont une autre
manière aussi d'appréhender l'univers
tech et donc c'est finalement se dire
ben hassine civilisation millénaire
il ya une énergie et un élan il ya
énormément de choses qui s'y passe et
donc autant aller aller à sa rencontre
pour pouvoir comprendre en effet ce cpi
l empire du milieu qui prend de plus en
plus de place sur la scène
internationale donc le prochain ouvrage
sera sur la chine ça sera en lien
probablement oui avec cette thématique
là comment vous voyez votre évolution
aussi professionnel parler de
communication on a parlé un peu de
journalisme tout à l'heure ses voyages
ses rencontres de l'économie aussi qui
vous intéressent
comme vous voyez la suite je trouve
justement c'est intéressant de pouvoir
lier ces différents univers et la
communication elle permet justement de
pouvoir tisser des liens en étant
attentive à ce qui se passe en étant
curieusement sans preuve de justement
et en mettant en lien les différents
univers donc ça c'est toujours ce qui
m'a toujours animé pouvoir apprendre
pouvoir tisser des liens et puis pouvoir
raconter à mettre en mais aussi ça ça a
été vraiment le fils du conducteur
vous êtes une ancienne élève du collège
blanche de castille puis du lycée la
bruyère à versailles vous avez intégré
une classe préparatoire philosophie le
celsa aussi on parlait de la
communication avec votre parcours votre
expérience c'est ce que vous avez des
envies de politique aussi alors c'est un
univers que je trouve passionnant je
vais essayer de vous raconter au
quotidien fréquentes j'ai été amené à
plusieurs reprises à décrypter la
communication politique et que je trouve
très intéressant depuis longtemps en
tant qu' en tant que citoyenne aussi ce
qui se passe par rapport à la
communication et savez que c'est
passionnant parce qu'il ya aussi des
rapports humains dans la manière dont on
s'est présentés dont les uns et les
autres se positionne donc c'est vrai que
c'est un bel univers et donc vous
pourriez être dans la communication
politique alors soit soit dans l'ombre
côté communication préparer des discours
guider un petit peu peut-être des
gouvernements qui ont quelquefois besoin
est
ou alors être carrément dans la lumière
candidate par exemple alors là pour le
moment c'est surtout des décryptages
seulement d'essayer de devoir de
comprendre comment les uns et les autres
se positionne et d'un point de vue
communication leur posture les messages
qu'ils essaient de transmettre et pour
arriver à être audible et c'est vrai que
c'est un vrai sujet sur tout ce qui se
passe en ce moment car on vient vous
porté sur la communication actuelle
entre le professionnel alors
généralement justement la communication
elle évolue beaucoup elle est
extrêmement personnalisé avec emmanuel
macron qui s'est beaucoup mis en avant
ces dernières semaines avec le grand
débat il ya aussi une accumulation
d'agendas qui se superposent
l'enjeu c'est finalement d'arrivée être
audible on avait la personnalité du chef
de l'état qui a été mise en avant qui a
été questionné et en même temps on voit
qu'ils essaient de retrouver une oralia
c'est une forme de verticalité une
volonté de se détacher du paysage
politique actuel d'inscrire dans une
vision il lui reste encore quelques
années dans son quinquennat justement
pour retrouver confirmé à sa stature
donc ça va être passionnant à
ivre puis on est on a un agenda aussi
qui arrivent les européennes et
municipales qui arrive on voit que les
les uns et les autres se positionne donc
ça va être passionnant à suivre la
communication vous n'avez que moins
d'une trentaine d'années mais la
communication a beaucoup évolué ces
dernières années
oui alors elle a évolué on en a 10 par
rapport aux réseaux sociaux mais aussi
par rapport à la proximité la manière
dont les uns et les autres se positionne
la volonté aussi de montrer de se
montrer en avant aussi avec voilà ces
failles entre qu'on est aussi un être
humain et puis le rapport aussi aux
médias a évolué la volonté de s'inscrire
à l'ère du tweet à l'ère des chaînes
d'information et du coup on n'est plus
dans un temps long comme on l'était
avant ce que disait jacques pilhan par
rapport à la parole rare et moins moins
évident et en même temps nécessaire en
ce moment donc il ya beaucoup de
questions qui se pose justement pour
arriver à se faire entendre auprès des
citoyens et des électeurs on n'est plus
dans l'immédiateté aujourd'hui pour
autant il faut travailler son style et
c'est le nom de votre ouvrage
on va terminer avec avec le travail que
vous avez menées ouvrage publié chez
ellipses que vous avez co écrire on y
trouve quoi l'intérieur des conseils
pratiques par exemple
oui absolument des conseils pratiques
beaucoup d'exemples d'illustration dans
la sphère politique des grands discours
des lettres aussi entre les écrivains et
puis des conseils justement pour arriver
aussi à apprendre à savourer les mots à
aller saisir pleinement et pouvoir mieux
écrire est en tout cas prendre plaisir à
écrire ça a été vraiment l'objectif de
cet ouvrage pour clara et moi merci
beaucoup
mathilde domino est revenu sur ce
plateau pour sauver il récupéra le titre
de votre ouvrage travail et son style
chez ellipses et on se retrouve bientôt
sur tv soixante dix huit pour un nouveau
v grippé
[Musique]